when Republicans selected their new
Speaker of the House Mike Johnson I was
at the time critical of the pick because
of some of the stances that Johnson has
taken in the past primarily I was
concerned with his past support of the
BLM narrative and his expressions of
outrage over the to use his word murder
of George Floyd but since then despite
these uh potentially serious qualms the
media have been doing everything in
their power to make me like speaker
Johnson they're not they're not doing
this on purpose of course they're uh
trying to make him look bad but as we
know nothing makes a a person look
better than when the media tries to make
them look bad and to that end they have
attacked Johnson repeatedly over the
last few weeks for um uh several reasons
mainly for being a Christian for being
socially conservative and for being a
Theocratic fascist now that last
description is not remotely accurate
sadly but when a person is attacked
along these lines it only gives them
more credibility and Johnson is in this
way uh racking up lots of credibility
and now we have the most desperate line
of attack of all so the the the latest
crime committed by the news Speaker of
the House according to the media and the
gaggle of brain dead leftist zombies on
Twitter is that get this he uh tried to
prevent his children from looking at
pornography and in the minds of these
porn crazed hyenas this is a big problem
this is an outrage uh Mike Johnson's
attempts to protect his children from
graphic sexual content is one of the
great political scandals of our time
what kind of freak doesn't want his kids
to watch porn they ask
incredulously now they're pretending
that they don't understand it they can't
possibly understand or maybe they're not
pretending maybe they really don't
understand why a parent wouldn't want
his kid to look at porn either way this
latest fax controversy like so many fax
controversies before it starts with a
rolling stone article Rolling Stone of
course is an amazing publication in a
certain way uh even amid a a media
landscape populated almost entirely by
lying scheming soulless parasites
Rolling Stone still manages to stand out
they you know they are the the gutter
journalists that make other gutter
journalists cringe and this article is
no exception and just to give you an
idea of how weak this hit piece is you
should know that the entire article is
from the Rolling Stone is just
373 words long that's because the
article is irrelevant they don't spend
much time on the story because there is
no story they just want to publish the
headline and the headline says this Mike
Johnson admits he and his son monitor
each other's porn intake in resurfaced
video now this framing has of course
been immediately adopted by other media
outlets and hundreds of leftists on
social media many articles and posts
have repeated it or a version of it the
left the left insists that uh this
supposedly this supposed Revelation is
is creepy and weird and and gross
they've called Johnson a predator and so
on and of course if this headline was
literally true if Rolling Stone was not
a worthless propaganda rag then we'd
have to agree you know you note the
carefully selected phrase porn intake
which suggests that Mike Johnson is
actively consuming porn and sharing the
material with his son porn intake means
that Johnson is a porn viewer and his
porn viewing is being monitored by one
of his kids in fact the website
political wire makes this claim
explicitly here's the headline Mike
Johnson admits his son monitors his porn
viewing now this implies doesn't really
imply but outright claims that Mike
Johnson is actively watching porn and
the porn is being shared with his son if
that was really the case then yes it
would be extremely
disgusting but it is not the case at all
it is a slanderous Lie by people who are
determined to make normal responsible
parenting into something bizarre and
even abusive this all becomes obvious if
you read the article to the extent that
there even is an article to read but
better yet you could just watch the
resurface clip for yourself to see what
he really said here it is Covenant eyes
is the software that I we've been using
a long time in our household uh I was I
first learned about it at I think a
promisekeepers event in the early 2000s
I think it was developed in about the
year 2000 uh but it's the largest um
accountability software that there is
and and there's some paperwork out there
on the table that I think everybody may
have picked up on the way in if not go
get it I it's a subscription based I we
don't make any money on this I'm telling
you we use it okay they're I'm not I'm
endorsing it because I'm a user uh it's
about $15 a month $16 a month something
like that and you get up to 10 devices
and what it is it's accountability
software so uh men in a church you know
men's bible study groups will do it
that's how it was presented at Promise
Keepers but they also mention hey when
your kids become teenagers especially if
you have boys dads they're talking to
the guys at this event you might want to
think about doing this with your sons
and so we've been doing that and so what
it does real real simply is it has an
algorithm and software it's way above my
head how it works but um it it scans you
you obviously opt into it but it scans
every all the activity on your phone or
your devices your laptop tablet what
have you we do all of it and then it
sends a report to your accountability
partner so my account accountability
partner right now is Jack my son right
and so he's 17 so he and I get a report
of all the things that are on our phones
or all of our devices once a week if
anything objectionable comes up your
accountability partner gets an immediate
notice I'm proud to tell you my son is
he's got a clean slate right okay okay
so what's the actual story here the
story is that Mike Johnson monitors his
child's internet usage to uh make sure
that his child is not accessing harmful
and objectionable material and the app
he's using Covenant eyes also gives his
son access to the content Johnson is
viewing on his own phone now anyone who
is not an insane idiot immediately
understands the point of this latter
step you have to be a perverted freak
yourself to see it as something perverse
Johnson is obviously trying to model
good behavior for his son he's not he's
not having his son monitor his porn
intake because there is no porn intake
the whole point is that Johnson doesn't
look at porn and he wants his teenage
son to know that he doesn't look at it
because is trying to be a good role
model this is called responsible
parenting and it may be necessary
because Johnson's teenage son is living
in a culture same as the rest of us
where people often claim that everyone
especially every man looks at porn porn
consumption is treated as some sort of
inevitability as if it's literally
physically impossible to refrain it it's
important for a teenage boy to know that
that isn't true okay it's a liee it is
possible to live free from the clutches
of porn it's it's more than possible and
there are plenty of men who are in fact
living that way this would seem to be
the point that Johnson is trying to make
to his son it's an important Point yet
again we're facing the threat of a
government shutdown later this month and
the administration will ultimately deal
with it the same way they always do with
more spending more spending will
inevitably devalue the dollar protect
your savings then by diversifying into
gold with the help of Birch gold group
and here's the best part when you open
an IRA with Birch gold for every
$110,000 you spend by December 22nd
Birch gold will send you a free gold bar
just text Walsh to 98 9898 to claim
eligibility before Black Friday Birch
gold can even help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
without taking any money out of pocket
and you still get the free gold bars too
with an A+ rating with a Better Business
Bureau thousands of satisfied customers
you can count on Birch gold to help you
transition an existing Ira into uh an
IRA in gold don't let your savings fall
victim to further devaluation of the
dollar text Walsh to
9898917350 if they happen to walk by uh
my parents didn't have their own
computer in their room or whatever they
used that one computer because they had
nothing to hide and they wanted us to
know that they had nothing to hide and
uh everyone just used the computers just
just that's it this is called setting a
good example which is a concept utterly
foreign to the leftist social media mob
now of course these days it's not
necessarily practical to have only one
stationary device with internet access
to be shared by everyone in the home so
smart parents in that case look for
other ways to practice openness and
accountability in cyberspace smart
parents or just smart people in general
parents or not understand that a desire
for secrecy on the internet wanting to
keep your internet activity hidden from
your loved ones is um almost always a
sign that you're doing things you should
not be doing uh things that are harmful
to you and to your
family now of course the left has looked
for other reasons to object to Johnson's
responsible parenting as well the
Rolling Stone throws another line of
attack against the wall quote outside of
the creepy BR Big Brother of it all
receip Maven also aired concerns about
whether Covenant eyes which is still a
working subscription based service might
compromise Johnson's devices if he's
still actively seeking accountability
quote a US congressman is allowing a
thirdparty tech company to scan all of
his electronic devices daily and then
uploading reports to his son about what
he's watching or not watching receip
Maven wrote uh I mean who else is
accessing that data now again if if you
think it's creepy or big brother for a
father to monitor his child's internet
usage you are simply too stupid to be
participating in this discussion or any
discussion the best thing you can do is
shut up you stupid child and let the
adults have this conversation now I
assume you're also the kind of person
who would say that telling a child to do
chores is forced labor sending him to
his room is false
imprisonment I can only take Sal in the
fact that most of these people are
childless Los ERS and will remain so for
the rest of their miserable lives which
is a good thing because they'd be
horrible parents but as for the other
concern I think we can use our our
brains and and assume that Johnson does
not have Covenant eyes installed on his
work devices pretty clear that he's
referring to his personal devices and
the ones in his home so in the end there
are two ways of interpreting this story
one interpretation is that Mike Johnson
has installed surveillance software on
all of his phones and computers
including his work phone and the
computer in his office on Capitol Hill
where he then proceeds to download an
unlimited supply of pornography which he
shares with his son the other
interpretation is that Johnson has this
accountability program on his family's
personal devices so that he can protect
his kids from pornographic content while
also modeling good behavior for them in
other words you can interpret this like
a deranged lunatic who can't comprehend
the English language or like a normal
sane person and that choice is really up
to
you but obviously this is not
really a matter of
misinterpretation uh we know the real
reason why the left is going after
Johnson for this and this is the real
point this is the most important
point that these are weak frail porn
obsessed automatons who lack willpower
and self-control and they feel shamed
they feel rebuked whenever they
encounter someone who doesn't look at
porn someone whose life isn't dominated
by it like theirs
is you know they view these people
people who try to live who make any
attempt at all really to live a virtuous
life they they view them with a a
mixture of
astonishment and hatred and of course
resentment and
envy they themselves being so
emasculated and feeble and weak and
pathetic can barely even con conceive of
the
possibility of not watching porn they
can't even wrap their heads around the
potential of not being a slave to your
vices they are themselves such slaves to
their own impulses that they think
anyone who exercises self-control is
some kind of
mutant and this is this is not just
about pornography by the way anyone who
engages in healthy practices in
basically any aspect of life is a freak
of nature in their eyes they
instinctively lash out against the
person because if they don't lash out
against that person who's trying to live
a healthy life and live a virtuous life
uh if they don't lash out if they don't
attack then the other option is that is
introspection right the other option is
that is that they see this person maybe
they see a family you they see parents
that are like attentive and care about
their kids and are making a real effort
to protect their kids and protect uh uh
their their
souls and they see that and they know
that they don't do any of
this and you know they can again lash
out at that person and try to destroy
them or they can look at themselves and
think
well man if this person can make healthy
choices and live a good moral life or at
least try to you know not perfect but
they're trying then maybe it's not as
impossible as I've convinced
myself you know maybe I'm living this
way not because it's impossible to live
any other way but just because I'm a
coward making excuses for
myself this is the rabbit hole that you
threaten to send these people tumbling
down if you attempt to live a virtuous
life in their
presence but they're too scared to take
the ride they're too timid and Craven to
actually look honestly at
themselves so instead they descend on
you and try to rip be to shreds for
committing the crime of being a better
person than
them hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there